Bruce Demi and their kids in a rare  reunion hey you guys I'm Katie Krause  and we've got the must-see family photo  rumor Willis's a whole family showed up  to be part of her world on Dancing with  the Stars on Monday night the 26 year  old web viewers and the judges with her  Samba - poor unfortunate souls from the  Little Mermaid and rumours whole family  including mom Demi and dad Bruce  reunited for a 21 year old sister  Tallulah called a quote rare family  photo on Instagram  23 year old sister scout is in there too  Bruce and Demi famously divorced in 2000  after 13 years of marriage rumoured  loved ravishing as Ursula and scored an  impressive 39 out of 40 with partner Val  Chmerkovskiy Demi sat front row to cheer  her on with Tallulah and scout while  Bruce and new wife Emma sat behind all  right you guys what did you think of  rumours routine she a front-runner to  win are you a fan let's be friends and  chat over on Twitter and bye for now